ما بين القفز والتسلق الجبال والهايكنج
ورحلات الكهوف يعيش الاماراته خليفه
الغافري مغامراته اليوميه اصبح الغافر
مشاهدينا يحمل لقب باتمان الامارات
نظرا تفاعات والقفز والتحليق في الهواء
الطلق بقفزات خطيره ايضا الغافري يمارس
هوايه القفز من فوق عاليه القمم الجبليه
منذ عام 2014 وحصل على شهادات معتمده في
تدريب في التدريب على تسلق الجبال كذلك
الطيران الشراعي
مشاهدينا في الاستوديو المغامر خليفه
الغافري
صباح النور والسرور ومرحبا شو اخبارك
طويل في الجبال وفي الوديان وفي السماء
وعلى الارض طيب هل كان في لك تجربه ببيئه
مشابهه للبيئه اللي ضلوا فيها الاطفال
الاربعه لمده 40 يوم
ادغال وفيها حيوانات مفترسه وما الى ذلك
انا صرت منطقه جبليه حلو
تحت الطريق جبرت اني استخدم معاي شو الجي
بي اس معاي وتلفون الثريه وسبحان الله
في برنامج تشتغل عن طريق الاوف لاين حصلت
مسار صغير وطلعت منه ووصلت على العشاء
تقريبا
اقول بانه يعني سواء تسلق الجبال او
الهايتينغ انت معرض ودائما تاخذ وياك عدتك
بانه انت قد ينقطع فيك الطريق او تضيع مثل
ما صار وياك فبالتالي تحاول النجاه شنو
اهم وسائل النجاح اول شيء اللي اسويه انه
مثلا حدد المسار اللي انا بسيره ذهاب
وعوده حلو واكلم صديقي هذا هو الطريق
المسار اللي انا بروحه هذا واحد اثنين هذا
قبل لا تروح قبل ما اروح تعطيهم تفاصيل
رحلتنا اثنين يكون معاي ماي 3 لتر 4 لتر
على حسب درجه الحراره
اثنين ثلاثه يكون عندي جي بي اس وعندي
برامج
خرائط في التليفون او ايش تحتاج انترنت
عن طريق الجي بي اس يعني اي نعم اوف لاين
ماب ولازم اخذ معاي مثلا اكلي مثلا المسار
تقريبا على حسب المسار 20 كيلو او 30 كيلو
اخذ الاكل حق يومين لازم
وسبحان الله اذا طحت او شيء اتصل حق الشخص
او يعني الفريق الثاني هم يسووا
فطبعا هو يعني انت كنت يعني ذاهب الى هذه
المغامره وانت محضر حالك بشكل جيد
هل مر عليك مواقف صعبه بحيث مثلا الجي بي
اس تليفونك خرب ما عندكش اي
وسيله تواصل مع اي شخص واضطريت انه انت
تعتمد على نفسك وعلى الاساليب البدائيه
الاساسيه
مثلا اسير مكان مثلا مؤشر سؤال مثلا اعرف
دخلتي وطلعت طلعه مثلا سواء مثلا امشي
مثلا اسوي علامه في ليبيل او على المكان
انا صاير ايه نعم وهو اهم شيء شو العامل
اول شيء من الشمس تقدر تعرف الاتجاه
الاتجاهات زين هذا من الشمع درجه الحراره
حلو
وحاول اني ما اكثر من ماي اقل الماي لان
ما انجز هاي المهمه عشان تكفي اما هي هذه
خليفه اليوم يعني ضربات الشمس
فقدانك للوعي لا سمح الله هذه شغلات ايضا
المغامر من انه ينتبه وياخذ وقايته من هذه
الاشياء الاطفال اللي قبل شوي في كولومبيا
يعني نجوا ايش كثرت تتحمل تاخذ وياك اكل
زياده ولا ما ياثر عني انا انا همشي عند
المي اهم شيء تقدر تصوم خمسه ايام بس
الماي ما تقدر اهم شيء هو يسوي مثلا
من نباتات حصل نباتات عادي
مثلا من الحيوانات
حتى بس على الاقل هذا الاكل كانه انت تقدر
تنجح بنفسك وفي طريق بدائيه مثلا
عن طريق الحصى او الحطب يعني في كذا طريقه
يعني عني انا استخدم هالمور تستخدم ايه
استخدمه
اشكرك جزيلا الشكر طبعا المغامر خليفه
الغافري كان معنا في الاستوديو لازم اطلع
وياك انا انا بسوي القفزه هذي انا خايف من
سالفه القفز بمظله ولا حتى بالاحداث
جبان ترى
كنت اخاف منه اصلا في الحور زين
وصلت
بسبب هذه الخوف من الخوف
على ارتفاع 2000 شو الموضوع الله يسلمك
قلت بطلع فوق بغيت اسوي جونغ ما قدرت خوف
فيني
وربي صديقي
دزني والنص تضحك علي سواء العرب والاجانب
الامور
قلت انا شو بسوي لازم اكسر الخوف ادخل
امور السكايد دخلت سكاي دايت احس انها
بسيط الناس كلها كلام بس الشخص اللي يخاف
يعني اني اتكلم عني انا شي انا ما اعرفه
اخاف انا لازم اكون واياك بطلعتك الجايه
وبجرب وياك
والله
تكسر قلبي شكرا جزيلا خليفه الغافري
المغامر الامارات يعطيك الف عافيه شكرا
الله يحفظك لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات